We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Get this idea out of your head. A stamp is not a tiny painting. Somebody might be able to do a great painting
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州和全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。把这个想法从你的脑子里赶走。邮票不是微型画。有人可能画得出一幅伟大的画，
20 by 30 inches, but you take that down to one inch by one and a half inches, and it's a challenge to make it work. And Ethel Kessler is just one of a handful of people who take on that challenge. I'm Ethel Kessler. Ethel's one of just five art directors responsible for churning out every single stamp issued by the United States Postal Service each year. And I've been doing that for 15 years.
20英寸乘30英寸，但如果你把它缩小到一英寸乘一英寸半，要让它发挥作用就是一种挑战。埃塞尔·凯斯勒（Ethel Kessler）只是少数接受这一挑战的人之一。我是埃塞尔·凯斯勒。埃塞尔是负责每年制作美国邮政署发行的每一枚邮票的五位艺术总监之一。我已经做了15年了。
Those bonsai stamps that just came out with the tiny little beautiful meticulous, detailed drawings of trees, those are hers. And our reporter there is Postal Service in Stamp Enthusiast, Julie Shapiro. Most people think of stamps and then picture flags or the Liberty Bell or the word love spelled in a cutesy font. But there are so many other stamps made every year. What about those abstract expression of stamps that were all sorts of awkward sizes, or the muppets that were out in a white background
那些刚发行的盆景邮票，上面有微小、美丽、细致入微的树木图画，都是她的作品。我们的记者是邮政服务和邮票爱好者朱莉·夏皮罗（Julie Shapiro）。大多数人想到邮票时，会想到旗帜、自由钟或用可爱字体拼写的“爱”字。但每年还有很多其他邮票被制作出来。那些各种尴尬尺寸的抽象表现主义邮票，或者以白色背景呈现的布偶邮票怎么样？
and seem to be bursting out of the envelopes? And those new pine ears of industrial design stamps? Oh my goodness. And I loved the cloud stamps. If you looked at the sheet, they're laid out in the exact same layers they exist in the sky. Every year, there are artful stamps, there are poetic stamps, there are stamps
它们看起来像是要从信封里爆出来一样？还有那些新的工业设计邮票？天哪。我喜欢云朵邮票。如果你看那张邮票纸，它们排列的层次与它们在天空中存在的层次完全一样。每年都有艺术邮票、诗意邮票、邮票，
with senses of humor, even surprising stamps. It's just that you don't really see those ones, you just see the flags, the bells, and the love. Stamps take on average a year to a year and a half from conception to execution. I can just tell you that this process is never succinct. Basically, the art directors pull together the stamps once the subject matter has been picked. But as Ethel mentioned, it's a long process. It starts with public suggestions for stamp subjects mailed to the USPS.
带有幽默感，甚至令人惊讶的邮票。只是你没怎么看到那些，你只看到了旗帜、钟声和“爱”。邮票从构思到执行平均需要一年到一年半的时间。我可以告诉你，这个过程绝不简洁。基本上，一旦主题选定，艺术总监就会把邮票汇集在一起。但正如埃塞尔提到的，这是一个漫长的过程。它始于公众寄给美国邮政署的邮票主题建议。
Yes, stamp proposals must be submitted in writing. Damn right, you have to use a stamp. The first thing is the subject. And that is our other guest, his name is Terry McCaffrey. My name is Terry McCaffrey and I recently retired as the manager of stamp development for the U.S. Postal Services, stamp services office where I was in charge of designing all the postage stamps for the government. There are 50,000 suggestions a year that come in from the American public. Basically, all of those subject suggestions
是的，邮票提案必须以书面形式提交。没错，你必须使用邮票。第一件事是主题。那是我们的另一位嘉宾，他的名字叫特里·麦卡弗里（Terry McCaffrey）。我的名字是特里·麦卡弗里，我最近从美国邮政署邮票服务办公室的邮票开发经理职位上退休，在那里我负责设计政府所有的邮票。每年有5万条来自美国公众的建议。基本上，所有这些主题建议
have to be gone through and have to be reviewed by a committee. The committee is called the Citizen Stamp Advisory Committee. That's CSAC for short, CSAC. And that committee serves the Postmaster General. As you might imagine, CSAC has received some pretty far out suggestions over the years. We've received requests for hate stamps to combat the love stamps that we issue every year, one for the devil, one for the passing of the Great American outhouse. But luckily there are rules that help guide the committee in choosing the stamp subjects.
都必须经过委员会的审查。该委员会被称为公民邮票咨询委员会。简称CSAC。该委员会为邮政局长服务。正如你可能想象的那样，CSAC多年来收到了一些非常离谱的建议。我们收到过要求发行“仇恨邮票”以对抗我们每年发行的“爱心邮票”的请求，一个是为了魔鬼，一个是为了纪念伟大的美国户外厕所。但幸运的是，有一些规则可以帮助指导委员会选择邮票主题。
About a dozen rules. They primarily feature Americans. Births, anniversaries, significant contributions. Dead presidents usually get a stamp. Fittieth anniversary of historical events. Fiftyth anniversaries of statehood. No repeats within 50 years, accepting national symbols and holidays. Two hundredth anniversaries of university findings.
大约有十几条规则。它们主要以美国人为特色。出生、周年纪念、重大贡献。已故总统通常会获得一枚邮票。历史事件五十周年。建州五十周年。50年内不得重复，国家象征和节日除外。大学成立两百周年。
No disasters commemorated. Keep away from religion. No, they have honored, of course, Christmas. And there have been a few people such as Mother Theresa, but we're really honoring her for her humanitarian efforts, not for her religious orders or religious beliefs. And this one is interesting. Themes of widespread appeal that reflect the USA's inclusiveness.
不纪念灾难。远离宗教。不，他们当然纪念过圣诞节。也有少数人，比如特蕾莎修女，但我们真正纪念的是她的人道主义努力，而不是她的宗教秩序或宗教信仰。这一点很有趣。具有广泛吸引力并反映美国包容性的主题。
In other words, something everyone will love. So being bold and controversial is not what stand-makers are going for, which I think you could view critically too. Although, you know, inclusiveness itself could be viewed as a radical notion to sum. But there's one more big rule, and we'll get to that in a minute. So the Citizen Stamp Advisory Committee follows these rules, picks the subjects, runs them by the Postmaster General, you know the Grand Poo Bob, the USPS. If he's not in favor of a stamp, it isn't going anywhere. But I think he usually defers to the committee, and assigns Bob, the USPS. If he's not in favor of a stamp, it isn't going anywhere.
换句话说，每个人都会喜欢的东西。所以大胆和有争议并不是邮票制作者的目标，我认为你也可以批判性地看待这一点。虽然，你知道，包容性本身对某些人来说可能被视为一种激进的概念。但还有一条大规则，我们稍后会谈到。所以公民邮票咨询委员会遵循这些规则，选择主题，并将其提交给邮政局长，你知道的，美国邮政署的大人物。如果他不赞成某枚邮票，它就哪儿也去不了。但我认为他通常会听从委员会的意见，并指派给艺术总监。
But I think he usually differs to the committee and assigns them to the art directors. And then the art directors follow their own rules. And the number one thing to keep in mind around the stamp services office. Our mantra courtesy of one of the art directors, Howard Payne, was to keep it simple and look at it at stamp size.
但我认为他通常会听从委员会的意见，并将其指派给艺术总监。然后艺术总监遵循他们自己的规则。在邮票服务办公室要记住的第一件事。我们的座右铭，由艺术总监霍华德·佩恩（Howard Payne）提供，就是保持简单，并以邮票大小来看待它。
But the art directors also consider a few other things. Keeping it bright and colorful and engaging and making the image something that people will want to put on their home ropes. What's the feeling you want to evoke? What emotions do you want to evoke? The social awareness stamps as we refer to them are the most difficult stamps to reduce
但艺术总监也会考虑其他一些事情。保持明亮、多彩和吸引人，并使图像成为人们愿意贴在自家信件上的东西。你想唤起什么感觉？你想唤起什么情绪？我们所说的社会意识邮票是最难缩小的邮票，
because you have to create an abstract concept and sell it to the American public. And there's one stamp that's been wildly successful in this. Both Terry and Ethel cited it independently. The first stamp that I have to mention... Dear to my heart for many reasons. It also happened to be the first stamp that was issued that I, our director, was a breast cancer stamp.
因为你必须创造一个抽象的概念并将其推销给美国公众。有一枚邮票在这方面取得了巨大的成功。特里和埃塞尔都独立提到了它。我必须提到的第一枚邮票……由于许多原因，它在我心中占据着重要的位置。它也恰好是我作为艺术总监发行的第一枚邮票，那是乳腺癌邮票。
Not only is it a great graphic design and illustration, but it also was a fabulous message stamp. And that stamp was also the first time in the country that the U.S. did a stamp that raised money for a cause in addition to the postage. Because you pay an extra 8 cents on the average to purchase each one of the stamps. That stamp, which went on sale in 1998. And it's still on sale after all these years. And it's raised about $73 million for breast cancer research.
它不仅是伟大的平面设计和插图，而且也是一枚极好的信息邮票。那枚邮票也是美国第一次发行除了邮资外还为事业筹款的邮票。因为你平均要多付8美分来购买每一枚邮票。那枚邮票于1998年开始销售。时至今日，它仍在销售。它已经为乳腺癌研究筹集了约7300万美元。
Just looking at the stamp from the lower left to the upper right, it goes from dark colors into bright colors, layered with a line drawing of the goddess Diana. Reaching over her shoulder to reach for an arrow in her quiver. Which also has an ingenious resemblance to the line drawn cartoons from those doctor's office pamphlets that explained how to give a self-pressed exam. Where her one bare breast would have been, they had removed that and put in a slogan,
只看这枚邮票，从左下角到右上角，它从深色过渡到明亮的颜色，层叠着女神戴安娜的线条画。她伸手越过肩膀去拿箭袋里的箭。这与那些解释如何进行自我检查的医生办公室小册子里的线条卡通画有着巧妙的相似之处。在她原本裸露的乳房位置，他们移除了它并放上了一个口号，
fun the fight, find a cure. So it was a brilliant design. But not all social awareness stamps are wildly successful. I think one of the biggest examples of a stamp gone wrong as many years ago before I joined the group, there was a stamp out alcoholism. But unfortunately, it was one of the biggest failures we ever had because when the message was sent to another person, that person received it and got the impression that the sender was saying, you're an alcoholic, you need help. And they found that offensive, so that's damp, did not work. As technology pulls us deeper into electronic correspondence
资助抗争，寻找治愈方法。所以这是一个绝妙的设计。但并非所有的社会意识邮票都非常成功。我认为邮票失败的最大例子之一是多年前，在我加入该小组之前，有一枚关于酗酒的邮票。但不幸的是，这是我们有史以来最大的失败之一，因为当信息被发送给另一个人时，那个人收到后得到的印象是发送者在说，你是个酒鬼，你需要帮助。他们觉得这很冒犯，所以那枚邮票没有成功。随着技术将我们更深地拉入电子通信，
and away from snail mail. A term the USPS hates, by the way. The USPS has lost billions of dollars, but it's trying to keep up and stay relevant. To that end, in the fall of 2011, they changed one of the biggest rules governing stamp subject selection. It used to be that first you had to be dead long enough
远离蜗牛邮件（顺便说一句，美国邮政署讨厌这个词）。美国邮政署损失了数十亿美元，但它正在努力跟上并保持相关性。为此，在2011年秋季，他们改变了管理邮票主题选择的最大规则之一。过去，你必须先去世足够长的时间，
to be on a stamp. And there were lots of reasons for that. In the beginning, they had to be dead 10 years. They shifted that to five. And as most people know, they've just shifted that to even living people can be on stamps. Now you have to start looking and saying, who's the first one? I had a feeling Terry knew the answer to that one.
才能出现在邮票上。这有很多原因。起初，他们必须去世10年。他们将其改为5年。正如大多数人所知，他们刚刚将其改为即使是活着的人也可以出现在邮票上。现在你必须开始观察并说，谁是第一个？我有一种感觉，特里知道那个问题的答案。
Yes, I do, but I'm not at liberty to say. It will not be Lady Gaga. See, when the USPS changed the deceased's subject rule to allow living people on stamps, they asked the public to nominate someone for the first living stamp. Tragically, nominations were accepted online. No stamps required. And besides Bob Dylan and at the time, living Steve Jobs, yep, Lady Gaga was right there near the top of the list.
是的，我知道，但我不能说。那不会是Lady Gaga。你看，当美国邮政署改变已故主题规则以允许活人出现在邮票上时，他们要求公众提名第一位活人邮票的人选。悲剧的是，提名是在网上接受的。不需要邮票。除了鲍勃·迪伦和当时的史蒂夫·乔布斯，是的，Lady Gaga就在名单的最顶端。
I said, well, you get what you ask for. Not that Lady Gaga is bad. I love her music. I just think it's a little premature to put her on a stand. This open call for the first living person, I see Eric can view it as kind of a gimmick to get people excited about the post office and get Lady Gaga fans to buy stamps.
我说，好吧，你得到你所要求的。并不是说Lady Gaga不好。我喜欢她的音乐。我只是觉得把她放在邮票上有点操之过急。这个对第一位活人的公开征集，我认为埃里克可以将其视为一种吸引人们对邮局感兴趣并让Lady Gaga粉丝购买邮票的噱头。
It will not be Lady Gaga. A boy can dream, can he? But for the people who design stamps, sure they want you to buy them. But when you talk to them immediately, you know there's so much more to it to them than that. As Ethel puts it, stamps tell the story of America in pictures. You work on these things so long and put so much into it. Heart and soul.
那不会是Lady Gaga。男孩可以做梦，不是吗？但对于设计邮票的人来说，当然他们希望你购买它们。但当你直接与他们交谈时，你知道对他们来说，这不仅仅是那样。正如埃塞尔所说，邮票用图片讲述了美国的故事。你在这件事上工作了这么久，投入了这么多。心血。
That you just feel like in the end, it has to be right. It's for the American public. That's who we're doing this for. And I just want it to be right. It's something that touches every person in the United States. And it's a product that I help develop and I think that to me is just wonderful and I'm honored to have been part of it. Oh, PS.
以至于你最终觉得它必须是正确的。这是为了美国公众。这就是我们为之做这件事的原因。我只是想让它正确。这是触及美国每个人的东西。这是一个我帮助开发的产品，我认为这对我来说非常棒，我很荣幸能参与其中。哦，附言。
In my opinion, 45 cents, the current rate for a first class stamp, is an entirely reasonable amount to pay for a tiny work of art that escorts your letter all the way across the country. I completely agree. For 45 cents, I wouldn't take your letter up stairs. And I'm going there anyway. Selection 13. Postal worker is canceling stamps at the University of Ghana Post Office. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Julie Shapiro, the artistic director of the third coast international audio festival. I've been telling people I want to get on the Citizen Stamp Advisory Committee. I've been new life goal. That's what I've taken from this little radio project. And believe me, I asked how to do it. I've got some awards to win, apparently. It's not going to happen anytime soon, but I'm working on it. And it was produced by me and Roman Mars with support
在我看来，45美分，目前一等邮票的价格，对于一件护送你的信件穿越全国的微型艺术品来说，是一个完全合理的支付金额。我完全同意。45美分，我甚至不会帮你把信件搬上楼。而且我本来就要去那里。第13节。邮政工人在加纳大学邮局取消邮票。《99%隐形》本周由第三海岸国际音频节艺术总监朱莉·夏皮罗制作。我一直告诉人们我想加入公民邮票咨询委员会。我有了新的人生目标。这就是我从这个小广播项目中得到的。相信我，我问过怎么做。显然我得赢得一些奖项。这不会很快发生，但我正在努力。它是由我和罗曼·马斯制作的，并得到了
from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. We're distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public, more at PRX.org. This week and every week I'm aided and embedded by Sam Greenspan. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but you can always tell me what your favorite stamp is and who you'd like to see on the first living person stamp at 99%invisible.org.
Lunar的支持，用创造力创造不同。这是旧金山KALW-91.7当地公共广播电台和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。我们由PRX分发，公共广播交易所让公共广播更公开，更多信息请访问PRX.org。本周和每周我都有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）的帮助和支持。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上是@RomanMars，但你总是可以告诉我你最喜欢的邮票是什么，以及你想在第一枚活人邮票上看到谁，网址是99%invisible.org。
Hey everyone, I have one more message. If you're new here, go ahead and download all the old episodes and try them out because they're all short, they're all evergreen, and I think you'll like them. Also, I want to thank everyone for all the Twitter mentions and Facebook sharing and ratings and reviews on iTunes. They're so amazing. You are the entirety of my marketing department. So I really need you. No pressure. But I just appreciate everything you've done so far. So thanks so much. And all right, I'm getting dangerously close to having a thousand ratings on iTunes.
嘿大家，我还有一个消息。如果你是新来的，去下载所有的旧剧集并试听一下，因为它们都很短，都很经典，我想你会喜欢的。此外，我要感谢大家在Twitter上的提及、Facebook分享以及iTunes上的评分和评论。它们太棒了。你们是我营销部门的全部。所以我真的很需要你们。没有压力。但我只是感谢你们迄今为止所做的一切。所以非常感谢。好的，我离在iTunes上获得一千个评分已经危险地接近了。
For a dude who does this independently at night in his bedroom, I think that that is amazing. So that really pleases me. So thank you so much for being so kind. And I'll keep making up some. Thanks. Bye. I'm not going to be a little bit more serious. I'm not going to be a little bit more serious. I'm not going to be a little bit more serious. I'm not going to be a little bit more serious.
对于一个晚上在卧室里独立做这件事的家伙来说，我认为这太棒了。所以这真的让我很高兴。所以非常感谢你们如此友善。我会继续制作一些。谢谢。再见。我不会再严肃一点了。我不会再严肃一点了。我不会再严肃一点了。我不会再严肃一点了。
I'm not going to be a little bit more serious. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不会再严肃一点了。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。